l'ultima volta che ho parlato con dei
cittadini dell'afghanistan è stato poco
meno di due anni fa ero al campo di
rifugiati di lesbo in grecia non
esattamente dentro al campo perché non
mi facevano entrare non fanno entrare
nessuno ma neanche loro erano stati
fatti entrare si erano accampati in dei
sacchi a pelo fuori dal campo perché il
recinto ea strapieno e tutto intorno
c'erano persone che venivano da tutto il
mondo
queste persone che venivano dall
afghanistan
avevano 15 16 il più grande aveva 17
anni e ha un gruppo di otto ragazzi
un paio di loro parlavano un inglese
spezzettato però potevamo comunicare e
uno di loro alzato la maglietta e mi ha
fatto vedere una cicatrice da qua acqua
è stato tagliato
aggredito da un talebano un altro mi ha
spiegato che ali in grecia è arrivato lì
perché ha dovuto scappare perché uno dei
suoi due genitori e a aveva lavorato
come interprete per le forze militari
occidentali
in quel caso britanniche questi ragazzi
avevano attraversato
naturalmente l'afghanistan perché va
alla frontiera lian tutta la turchia a
piedi prevalentemente con qualche
passaggio di autostop ma prevalentemente
a piedi adesso non sapevano dove andare
neanche il campo di rifugiati di lesbo
li aveva accolti figurarsi l'europa
bene ovviamente non ho potuto fare a
meno di ripensare a quelle facce a quei
ragazzi in questi giorni e devo dirvi
che la cosa che mi colpisce di più che
fosse dovrebbe colpire e far riflette
più noi tutti riguarda i tempi
se ci pensate quello che sta succedendo
si caratterizza per la contrazione e
l'accelerazione improvvisa del tempo
prima
le forze dell'intelligence ci avevano
raccontato che se gli occidentali si
fossero ritirati gli americani se
fossero ritirati forse i talebani in un
anno e mezzo abbiamo preso kabul poi
dopo è diventato forse in qualche mese
che abbiamo preso kabul
poi abbiamo iniziato a parlare
probabilmente entro qualche settimana
avrebbero preso capu kabul il mese
prossimo e abbiamo iniziato a raccontare
dei talebani a kabul quando ancora
stavamo parlando del mese prossimo
e poco dopo è il momento in cui stavamo
parlando fra un anno e mezzo
non avevamo la più pallida idea non solo
di quello che sarebbe successo anzi
soprattutto non tanto di quello che
sarebbe successo ma dei tempi e questo
mi suona come giornalista come persona
che dà appunto da 30 anni ahimè da 30
anni segue l'attualità
straordinariamente familiare perché se
c'è una caratteristica è un modo con cui
si può raccontare la storia del xxi
secolo
dal nostro punto di vista dal punto di
vista di persone agiate occidentali e in
questa incapacità di capire i tempi nei
quali accadono le crisi sistemiche
arriviamo sempre a confrontare dei fatti
che non avevamo previsto
iniziamo a prevedere dei fatti che
stanno già accadendo
vi faccio degli esempi
l'attentato dell 11 settembre di cui
ricorderemo i 20 anni tra pochi giorni
ormai era stato
annunciato dalle forze dell'intelligence
americana
ma non ci si era creduto
l'amministrazione non ci aveva creduto
un anno prima al qaeda aveva colpito dei
bersagli americani importanti da us sco
e l'aveva distrutta
ma anche altri crisi sistemiche se voi
ci pensate la banca centrale europea
alza i tassi di interesse dunque
respinge i fattori di crescita
dell'economia nel pieno delle crisi
finanziarie sistemiche che abbiamo avuto
nel 2008 e nel 2011
i banchieri centrali europei non avevano
assolutamente capito la situazione in
cui ci trovavamo tutti non solo questo
ma nessuno di noi io compreso
ha preso carta e penna per criticarli
perché neanche io avevo capito quanto
sbagliato fosse
potremmo andare avanti con gli esempi ma
ve ne do solo uno che riguarda la
pandemia al momento in cui esplode la
pandemia nel resto d'europa si pensa che
sostanzialmente sia un problema italiano
perché in fondo noi siamo i soliti
italiani disorganizzati e in effetti la
protezione civile italiana si è scoperto
solo ex post non aveva neanche uno stock
di mascherine come quelle che oggi
portiamo tutte nell'evento di una crisi
pandemica e questo ovviamente visto
esposte profondamente irrazionale e
ancora una volta un non riuscire ad
anticipare le svolte o capire che le
svolte sono arrivate solo invitato
perché in questo secolo noi abbiamo
avuto la sars abbiamo avuto ebola
abbiamo avuto zica abbiamo avuto la
febbre mediorientale emerse abbiamo
avuto la suina abbiamo avuto l'aviaria
e ha tutto sommato non molto improbabile
che prima o poi una pandemia sarebbe
sfuggita di mano
eppure non lo abbiamo capito
e come se tutti questi eventi sistemici
un po come sta succedendo con
l'afghanistan oggi non solo per noi ma
persino per il presidente degli stati
uniti
andassero a
colpire una specie di angolo cieco della
nostra mente per cui non riusciamo a
pensare fuori dagli schemi di quello che
abbiamo conosciuto fino a ieri
continuiamo a pensare che il presente e
soprattutto il futuro siano una
proiezione tutto sommato linea e del
passato che noi così come noi pensiamo
di averlo capito
o a
tutto questo naturalmente non è tipico
solo degli americani non è tipico solo
degli italiani
io credo che sia tipico della natura
umana ma per provare a capire
in che modo noi guardiamo queste cose ho
fatto un piccolo esperimento
comportamentale c'è un posto che è il
massimo del rischio sistemico al mondo
sono le pendici di un vulcano
pendici di un vulcano attivo
noi abbiamo la certezza non sappiamo se
oggi domani dopodomani tra cento anni o
tra mille anni
succederà qualcosa di devastante
bene in italia c'è un vulcano alle cui
pendici di 12 milioni di persone
ercolano è stata distrutta
molte volte nella sua storia
naturalmente nel 79 dopo cristo è stata
distrutta nel xvii secolo e ogni volta
che viene distrutta
gli uomini ricostruiscono sulle macerie
dell'ercolano che fu
tutt'oggi le persone vivono
letteralmente avendo sotto il tinello di
casa le rovine dell'ascolano di quino il
vecchio
sono andato là e ho chiesto alle persone
ma ha mai pensato che potrebbe esserci
un rischio nel vive alle pendici del
vulcano
sapete qual è la keys fosse che mi hanno
dato più di frequente
la risposta più frequente circa il 60
per cento dei casi è stata sì qualche
volta mi è venuto in mente ma preferisco
non pensarci
ora noi potremmo come dire
liquidare una risposta del genere un po
come folklore napoletano ma invece no
questo modo di pensare
profondamente connaturato non so se con
la natura umana sicuramente con la
psicologia della nostra società è un
modo che ci rende vulnerabili perché
rifiutiamo di confrontarci con
l'incertezza radicale proprio quando
l'incertezza radicale per la natura
delle dei rapporti nel xxi secolo è una
caratteristica del nostro tempo
pensiamo ancora una volta l'afghanistan
e cosa significa incertezza radicale
quando allarga le sue onde d'urto in
maniera concentrica noi vediamo già in
questo momento che dovevo pestano
dicendo per carità non vogliamo
rifugiati ondate di rifugiati
dall'afghanistan già oggi 5 milioni di
afgani vivono fuori dal paese sono
rifugiati gli europei ancora prima che
succeda stanno dicendo lo ha detto il
presidente francese manuel matrone
l'hanno detto l'ha detto ministro
dell'interno ossia quello lo dicono
politici italiani non li vogliamo ancora
prima che escano ma con il dirlo noi
stiamo dicendo un'altra cosa
noi stiamo dicendo ai taliban in questo
caso noi siamo vulnerabili perché se
volete riduce al silenzio e metterci in
ginocchio non avete che da minaccia ed
di buttare fuori tutti quelli che non
vogliono convive col con i talebani
cinque milioni di persone
e questo è esattamente quello che fanno
i paesi intorno a noi perché noi lo
vediamo accadere
con la turchia che minacciano date dei
rifugiati il marocco che lo fa con la
spagna addirittura la bielorussia ha
incominciato a importare rifugiati dal
medio oriente dall'africa per buttare
addosso agli europei come arma di
pressione
questo è caratteristico questo modo di
pensare questo modo di essere
vulnerabili e caratteristico di una
bella
io penso della demografia del mondo se
voi prendete i regimi politici nel mondo
catalogati per il grado di libertà
individuale rispetto dei diritti
personali e democrazia e li metteteli
confrontate con l'età media delle
popolazioni scoprirete una cosa oggi i
soli paesi liberi sono paesi anziani non
ci sono paesi democratici nei quali la
popolazione è giovane ma qual è la
caratteristica delle persone anziane c'è
qualcuno che dopo di me anche più auto
autorevolmente la caratteristica è sì di
avere una grande esperienza del passato
ma di esse è tendenzialmente
conservatori
tendenzialmente avversi al rischio
io penso che questa mentalità sia
profondamente in co e tendenzialmente
incapaci di capire le strizzate radicali
del nostro tempo
questa mentalità e profondamente
incompatibile con la natura del nostro
secolo
avrei bisogno di ben più di altri 10
minuti per parlare dei medi ma riesco
esprime solo un desiderio e un auspicio
è che troviamo nelle nostre società
anziane un modo per dare voce e da e
potere ai giovani molto più di quanto
stiamo facendo in questo momento
[Applauso]